[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie Guide one of the
only shows that talk about these smaller
films that are out in theaters this
weekend and luckily because we have
three great films that all are very
unique and all have a great independent
spirit about them let's start with guk
directed by justin chon now GOOG is a
derogatory term but it's also the title
of the film this is set in 1992 on the
day of the Rodney King trials in LA it
all takes place in South Central Los
Angeles where racial tensions are high
and everything is bubbling to the
surface about to take off and spill over
into riots justin chon is not only the
director of the film he's also the star
he plays eli one of two korean-american
boys who are looking after a shoe store
and they befriend a young
african-american girl me know we only
got a smaller size you're gonna have to
wait a few years to yeah little
[Music]
it's all shot in black and white which
does give it kind of 1990s feel like
clerks justin is definitely a director
that has something to say and I'm so
glad that he is telling these stories
who that's not very often that we see
Korean Americans at the center of
stories motion dr. Miller gusta story
and not your friend egg using family the
ending is a little bit cliche but it
feels like a very vibrant piece of work
support independent cinema like this
check out [ __ ] it's available in limited
theaters this weekend note it down if
you can't see it this weekend hopefully
you'll see it in the future
[Music]
another very unique independent original
film is called lemon it's directed by
Jeannette scab Bravo with a script by
Jim it's car and her real-life husband
Brett Gelman who also stars in the film
how do you 3540 how much you weigh 165
well that's a to 20 to be safe thank you
so much for coming in thank you he plays
Isaac a struggling actor who's also an
acting teacher his blind girlfriend of
10 years has just broken up with him his
life is a bit of a mess Tracy what am I
going to say that I'm bad have you ever
thrown a knife hey do you mind not doing
that lemon is a very dark comedy and I
love how it puts you on the edge it
makes you feel very uncomfortable and I
love movies that make you feel something
even if it is uncomfortable
I think Jeanette's go Bravo is so good
at looking at alienation and Brett
Gelman is such a likeable actor that
even if his character is doing
despicable things you're still kind of
cheering for him I want you to meet a
guy I was mugged it was a game a lot you
know getting out of black gained a lot
of people still think black when you say
gang is that right there are
embarrassing moments hilarious moments
and great cameos particularly by Michael
Cera and Gillian Jacobs there is so much
going on lemon will definitely not be
everyone's cup of tea but would we want
it any other way
make sure you see lemon it is out in
limited theaters this weekend and going
wider very soon
I heard screaming but I'm having a heart
attack and last but not least the
wonderful film
patty-cakes which is very independent
it's like a rap musical starring an
unlikely protagonist played by
Australian actress Daniel McDonald she's
a character that gets bullied everyday
she's in this horrible family situation
that she feels like she can't get out of
but she wants to make her world better
and she wants to go after her dreams of
becoming a rap star
it's got great music I love the fantasy
scenes in this and it really does
introduce the world to Daniel McDonald
who I think will be a big star
[Music]
[Music]
it's written and directed by Jeremy
Jasper at times it does feel like a
conventional coming-of-age story but
just when you think you know where it's
going to go it takes a turn and takes
you somewhere fresh and unexpected it's
also inspirational in standing up to
your haters and purely for leaving in
yourself
patty-cakes is out in cinemas this
weekend don't miss it - give it up - to
call world over
[Applause]
so to recap three very unique
uncompromising independently made movies
check out Guk directed by justin chon
lemon directed by Janet Scott Bravo and
patty-cakes directed by Jeremy Jasper
I'm Alisha Malone you can always contact
me on Twitter at Alicia Malone all let
me know in the comments below if any of
those films take your fancy and what's a
movie for you that really does celebrate
an independent spirit I'm Alicia Malone
I'll see you soon
[Music]